hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to security breach it's
time to bowl
how i bowl i'm not armed
but it's time
to
bowl
this is not bowling
this is an arcade
ah
okay well that's not what i was going
for i assumed that there was bowling
happening here i might have been wrong
ah
that looks like it might be bowling
hello
[Music]
freddy no still no freddie here hey hey
watch yourself
okay
bowling i'm gonna need some shoes i'm
gonna need some
balls i'm gonna need
to know what the hell i'm doing
i'm gonna need to do a whole lot of
things
i'm sorry
what the hell was that
okay hi
hey
you look like baby
a little bit
why
why do you look like baby
hi can i get a pizza can i get a
milkshake can i get a hamburger could i
get literally anything
can i get some service ice cream
could i get something
oh
uh
[Music]
okay
hi buds how are you doing
oh god
well i don't like that
hi can i get some
no
all right
well
is bonnie around could bonnie answer me
some things because um haven't seen bon
bon
for a little bit
could uh use some advice on what's going
on around here
okey-dokey
a little uh
creepy
oh no we got here pink slip good news
due to the success of the staff project
we will no longer need nighttime
employee coverage we will be reducing
nighttime hours effective immediately
enjoy the additional time spent with
your families
great
parts and service is concerned that
chica will suffer heavy damage if she
ever gets caught in a trash compactor
always double check the compactor before
use do not use the compactor to dispose
of pizza pizza flavored items or
pizza-scented materials especially
monty's mystery mix otherwise her
replacement costs will come out of your
paycheck
uh-huh
well that's a subtle hint
i don't know what to do with that
information
oh well
once again i think i'm lost just with no
idea what to do
oh
hi
what's with these golden boxes golden
monty
[Music]
okay whatever so i wasn't supposed to
come down here is that what the answer
to that was
this was just a uh
side piece of this whole
ordeal all right
so uh
i'm gonna try to figure out how to bowl
here
bathroom the bathroom starts with bb
this is bowling a bowl in the bathroom
toilet
toilet bowl
how about
them men's bathroom
i swear the staff robots in this game
are scarier than anything
that's all right you don't need to do
that i will hide
not me i'm good thanks
my friendly security staff can help
good
okay thank you
bowling bowling bowling maybe i gotta go
down to the bowling alley to bowl what
are you doing looking at that
are you trying to decide if you want a
bowl or not
i'd play a game with you baby
you seem to be a little preoccupied
there's something over there
i don't know if that's going to help me
but there is something over there what
did i come here for there's probably a
specific reason right
find the monty mystery mix that's right
i'm looking for ice cream
i forgot about the iced cream
that means it must have been in the bag
somewhere that was an ice cream parlor
over there
must have been maybe i don't know
messages there's a princess quest one
machine somewhere in the building an
actual stand-up arcade i guess the devs
pulled it from that old mobile game why
ported to arcade
i don't know
why ported to arcade
that is an excellent question is that a
clue that i'm supposed to go to the
arcade and look for the princess one
thing
i mean i know i'm supposed to go find
the money mystery mix but
this message is a little strange why
would you port
said game over to arcade unless there
was something to
do about that
fredbear's nom nom bits
the bed maker
mega void
multi-match
hey
okay
was like princess something
house of the bear
clown town throwdown
i love these names ends with stars
sure it does
free morph this
death stretch
i lo i would play any of these games
i would play all of these games
worst wild
button mash
okay
okay i don't think there's anything here
quarter eater
okay
nah
i don't think so
i mean maybe but
i'm not really here to go super deep
if this is like a sidequest easter egg
thing milk spoiled very fun very fun all
right let's go get that ice cream
there's got to be something back there
that i didn't see
or like some kind of
freezer or something that i could look
in
to find the monty mystery mix
but what would happen if i get the monty
mystery mix and then it just seems like
you know chica would be really
interested in me
and i'm not about that
i don't have time to deal with the
advances of animatronics
hello monty mystery mix
was it down there and i just didn't look
hard enough
that seems very
likely cool
no
definitely not i don't see it here
unless it's up there
is that the monty mystery mix huh didn't
make it
oh hi
what are you doing up there
ah good to see you
i could try to go ah this isn't much for
like
the movement isn't good enough for me
doing stuff like that so the monty
mystery mix must be up in the ice cream
area they said something about
them putting it away i remember there
being a message
uh
chica rapport recalled monty mischief we
have no
hide the mix
behind the to the frozen ice cream
storage behind the bowling alley okay
there must be another path to get
through here to get behind the bowling
alley
that's what i'm gathering from this
because if this isn't behind the bowling
alley
oh hello are you the mon are you the ice
cream mix
oh
i couldn't have just gotten that
it's kind of confusing when everything
is in a box
looks like it's over there because the
art on the thing was
like that box anyway i got it now so now
that i have that i go to the trash
compactor i smash chica to bits i grab
her
eyeballs
no she didn't have the eyeballs she had
something else
ear balls she had something
she had something else
i don't remember what it was
specifically but i know she had
something else in a ball shape that i'm
going to extract
from her smoldering corpse
which is exactly what i've always wanted
to do
and game on where am i going oh hi
hello hi good to see you
no no yes i do actually take one of
these thank you
bye
goodbye
i'm off
high
i'm off to go smash cheek into bits
yes i can
this is not my laser
right between the eyes right but twix
this is not the way to go i thought
there was a way down here what's over
here oh level 10 bam
well sucks for you
and if this does that to animatronics
what does it do to
what does it do to people
why is that one
yes uh-huh yeah why is this one
electrified
whoa
nah
i won't
[Laughter]
man i didn't even get to play a game of
bowling
that's kind of sad
all that lovely bowling alley for a bit
of ice cream in the back
that's all i get
oh well this is what i'm looking for
bam okay so once i get down there
i either put the ice cream mix in the
trash compactor or i
don't
that's really the only option that i
have
there's no way that i could do anything
else right
ready no no freddie here either
all right well
i'm hoping it's a straight shot but i
got a laser if it's not
it is interesting that there have been
kind of like different choices that oh
my god
you guys whoa where where where stop
what do i do with it here
i'm in the trash compactor uh
do i
use monty mystery mix in the kitchen
compactor okay
how how
oh i did it i did the thing where is it
there it is
hey chica go get it
oh my god stop that
okay if you could not
can you come get this
look it's uh it's a monty mystery mix
it's mystery monty mix
mega monty mystery mix
yeah yeah
hi buddy
don't tell her where i am
don't tell her you told her
you have no idea where i am right
good
excellent don't don't oh my god
what
are you doing to me my guys
okay
so i did that
so now i just gotta decommission chica
i think
oh my gosh
what if i just push the button that was
my phone okay i just pushed the button
hi
oh
all right well this is easy
ah
that's the compact oh
oh
everything's fine don't worry about it
am i really strong enough to do that
i guess i am
oh hi
oh
voice box
i'll take that thank you very much
ah
good
turn on the generators okay
great
okay
wow that was easy
where am i
oh
uh uh-huh
okay
this is a little strange don't know why
this is all needed in a megaplex
but uh sorry um
i'm sure they'll fix you right back up
ooh
there's a some people's pizza boxes if
you want them all right bye
saving okay where is me and i did want
to go in the sewer so honestly i'm
pretty grateful about this
this is pretty dope there's probably
some presents buried down here don't
know why but i just have a big feeling
that there's some presents down here
maybe actually back in that area over
there there might be some presents
you're not sitting up are you nah same
space
okay well i don't see any and i don't
have the pacers to go find them so i
unless they're right in front of me the
lore will come to me as it always do the
wind seems to be rustling quite nicely
in this area
always good to keep your sewers breezy
oh hey that's helpful and away
wow don't like that
can't press that
i guess this way i go
monty are you down here
oh my god
oh my god hi
oh my god i hate that
oh
that is awful
that is horrifying
why is that like that why would that
ever be like that
that's the worst okay
cool thanks
i hate it
uh
give it a few hours and that character's
gonna have a name and a backstory
you guys are insatiable
i don't know
what
what is this
is this something someone else set up or
is there
was chica's spending time down here what
the hell
not she good because there's an uneaten
pizza
and if it was a real
chica
there would be no pizza left
all right turn on a generator i know i
need to find three of these things
okay
that's one
good
oh hi
why are you rigged up
oh
no no no no
no no no
okay that still works
worried that wasn't gonna work
nope okay you are being incessant
i'm saying no and you should take that
for an answer oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god
okay you are
too much
i'm just looking around if there's any
like secrets or something but there
doesn't seem to be so i'm out of here
oh hey where'd you come from that
doesn't make any sense
okay bye
please don't find me again please don't
teleport in front of me that'd be very
nice if you could do that
ah
okay open yes yes yes good good good
excellent excellent excellent good great
oh rickety okay can i fall off and die
i'm not gonna try
i don't know why i even had that
instinct
i'm not gonna jump into this pit to test
whether or not i can die or not
oh my god
i don't know when the last time i saved
us
god that was not worth it
why would i do that
god why is that an instinct
i should not go near cliff's edges
uh
all right where am i oh god damn it okay
sure sure okay i'm not too far i'll be
right back okay
now i'm not gonna jump into the pit i'm
not gonna jump into the pit i'm just not
i won't i refuse i shan't i shouldn't
i know they put those oh my god i almost
fell in the pit
i'm not gonna jump at the pit even my
game is trying to pull me into the pit
i'm not gonna jump into the pit why
would i do that that'd be very dumb be
very dumb
be exceptionally dumb of me
i'd be big dumb
and i'm not big dumb
small dumb
big smart
big smart big brain
big smart big not small brain
all right
okay just a few more of these generators
and a few more nightmares to add on to
my collection of horrors that haunt me
in my dreams
alas i shan't have a good
night's sleep ever again oh wow oh wow
oh yeah
i bet that's a nice pit to jump into
not gonna
do that
okay well we got underground mines here
and uh
okay
great
good
i don't know where i'm going is this
literally being held held up by sticks
cause uh that seems to be a problem
there's a wire over here i'm guessing
that the wire is going to lead nope
yep nope yep no
no yes yes no yes
oh hands
excellent
yeah excellent
okay
good
all right
i'm gonna be lost forever
ah a brick wall good
oh
i made it i'm a genius
my big brain is throbbing
i know
mentally just moving through my brain i
never mind everyone shut up shut up i'm
gonna go save and then i'm gonna keep
going okay
good don't know why the super
underground parts of this game are the
scariest but whatever i'm not
complaining
it's fine
oh there was a save right here well that
would have been convenient but alas i
thought you weren't going to give me any
saves
maybe if you made a good auto save
system that would uh not have to use so
many of these but whatever
okay
unless you're just tempting me with more
pits to fall into
oh oh oh hey hey hey
hey
no
why are you so dirty
whoa
whoa oh my god i was not that close to
you i'm hopping in i'm hopping in
hi
you shan't ever find me you're too
stupid he's an idiot
okay well we got upgraded terrifying
uh staff bots as if they weren't
horrifying before
now they're extra horrifying
don't find me don't find me don't find
me destruction
destruction
oh that looks fun actually that looks it
looks dangerous
which means it's fun
hi
there doesn't seem to be a to where hey
no no no okay well you know uh that
that's interesting
no wait hold on
you don't want to look in here you don't
want to
no no
no no no no no
no no no
oh no
are you stuck there
no please not like this okay
mercy was granted to me okay thank you
thank you very much
go away
who made you like that oh god oh god
play fight hi i'm i'll do this okay good
generator
i did it
there anything else i need to find gift
gift gift gift gift nope i'm out
bye
goodbye
bye-bye
take one of these
oh god you're not affected by one of
them
[Music]
okay
ah
well let's try that again
shall we wow god hi hello yeah
okay don't worry about that don't worry
about that don't worry about why don't
you just uh look at the look at the
pretty colors look at the pretty colors
look at the pretty colors look at the
are you looking to stop
look at the pretty colors
no no no
okay so gun don't work on vani
probably because vani not anna matromo
probably because vani
is uh a human in a bunny suit
i'm not looking by me this time i am not
looking behind me i'm not gonna wait
around for something to come find me
i'm just not gonna look behind me
there's nothing there's nothing it's
actually surprising how much nothing
there is
uh
okay oh
oh
this is fine
this is fine anyone want to decode that
binary
this is fine this is my home leave okay
great
good
as i say
grown-ups only
uh-huh
i'm not grown-up
apparently
what's with all the tubes
what's with the tubes
what are the tubes all about
okay am i going up to vanny's office
is this where this leads
not an extremely convenient place to get
to
nope this oh it's this place
oh it's here i was in there when i was
going through laundry hell
oh i'm here
interesting
very interesting
very interesting see this is the kind of
stuff about an open map that i like
looping back to places that organically
put you where you've seen them before i
like that i like that a lot actually can
i just open that
no
yes i can
okay
is there anything else here that i need
or am i going through laundry hell again
i guess there's nothing else i'll just
go through laundry hell again
so i've gotten out
but now the question is what do i do
with my out there were some
level three security doors over here
that i wasn't able to get to before
kind of curious where they go now
huh
uh laundry oh
it goes to the laundry
this is not laundry
oh where am i now oh
don't mind if i do
as requested here are my notes on
today's chief security officer interview
while vanessa seemed eager and bright
she doesn't appear to have any relevant
background experience i realized the
recommendation came from the top but we
need someone who has run security for a
facility of this scale i do not
recommend her for this position and yet
look
here she is anyway
wouldn't you know it
okay interesting
so this put me back
here
but if i'm gonna upgrade the old
fredsters
i'm gonna need to get back to that
basement area which is accessible
through the elevators
from the ass backside of
oh oh freddy
hey fredster what you up to
all right
upgrade freddie and parts and service i
gotta go to parts and service okay
freddy you ready for an upgrade chica
won't be bothering us anymore or did i
see a shadow in that corner
[Applause]
did you guys see like a squiggly looking
shadow
i swear it's uh
really squiggly shadow
okay whatever
so parts and services freddy get in here
thanks bud
no no no no i don't need that i'm a big
boy
i can do it all by myself
so anyway since you're not going to talk
to me
we're going to go down to parts and
services and i'm going to shove a beak
inside of you and you are going to be
able to talk better
you
did you hate the idea that much
freddy
[Music]
i swear it was a good idea
the voice in my watch told me to do it
and i thought that was your voice all
right fine whatever
roxy you're next unless it's monty and
then you're next next because you're
last your last
idiot okay so parts and services
if i go back to rockstar row which might
be accessible from this direction
something no it won't be because that's
not true
but if i go to rockstar row
i can get through i believe it was no
did i pop through the vent there no
no no yes no yes no
roxy roxy
there's an elevator in the back of those
or
can i still take the main stage
down is that a shortcut
is that a shortcut
hey
all right well that saved me some time i
could just take this down ready
ready
all right fine freddy be like that
friday
why there you are come on man there you
are okay
follow me
come with me please freddy
freddy
ready ready
come with me we gotta get you upgraded
let me save first because i have a funny
feeling you're gonna kill me
and that's not what friends do to other
friends
those are some beefy claws
and
schwab
okay good ready come here
ready there you are what do you do
looking at the prisoner cells uh sure
all right voice box
insert preparing for upgrade procedure
you may now enter the protective
cylinder oh freddie you're there already
now that's some uh proactive ability
all right what are we doing more simon
says i have a funny feeling not
okay to access the voice box we must
open freddie's chest cavity to unlock
the chest cavity remove freddy's bow tie
i mean i've been in here before so uh
click on the bow tie to take it off
thanks i
i got it that much
good job now remove the chest plate
yeah okay all right thank you
well done disconnect the throat wires to
continue it is important that you match
the pattern correctly
[Music]
okay
okay click on the voice button i get it
i get it i get it my guy
good job now connect the throat wires to
the replacement voice box
why did i want to do this
oh
okay
[Music]
well done return the chest plate and
firmly lock it down with the bow tie
looking spiffy commence testing phase
oh no
[Music]
that's not good
okay
[Music]
i i can't get it thank you thing phase
complete activating safety protocols
you mean those weren't activated before
oh you disabled them once i entered the
safety chamber
okay
[Music]
press left mouse button to use chica's
voice box to stun other animatronics
hurry
this upgrade
it was chicas
please be honest
how did you get it when i was in the
kitchen earlier she fell into some sort
of garbage smasher is she okay
well
she's still functional that is a relief
with this new voice box i should be able
to make a vocal pitch that will stun
animatronics
let's go to recharge station and let's
blast this thing out a
century
excuse me we gotta go blast
okay
i am very glad that you made it to the
retreat station gregory now that i have
been upgraded i should be able to access
the roxy raceway i have not been there
for a very long time but perhaps you can
find some clues on how to deal with roxy
while you are there what's up with your
voice man
rarr
there are
okay never mind then
hey
what are you doing okay it's fine
um
well all right
so the question i have now is uh why the
hell you talking so creepy
why the hell you talk so creepy you're
talking real creep and i don't like it
and also you seem to be filthy er than
you were before which was pretty filthy
okay
all right
great
ah
okay
um
so the quickest way back would probably
probably just take one of these up
i don't know if this is going to be the
one but i'll take it
huh time to go for a race with roxy
that's always fun
hi pal hey good to see you
okay now that we're here
god that's creepy
hey how you doing pal
good to see you good to see you all
right you stay there
okay
utility tunnels
uh
requires freddy get over here
freddy really
freddie please there he is all right
don't run out of power please
actually wait don't you have you have a
power thing right in your own little
doodad right in the back
don't you
don't you oh my
what
[Music]
wha
freddie we were friends
freddie we were the best of friends
what in the hell
is it cause you ran out of power
why would you do that to your friend
kind of a dick move was that
all right so the moral of that story is
don't let freddie run out of power now
that he's got a few upgrades he gets a
little sassy you know you become a star
and then you just like get so full of
yourself
that you forget about the friends that
you made along the way you know you
really uh you really just like let it
all go to your head
this guy this guy
happens to everybody oh hi
excuse me
come on freddy hurry up we got places to
be
ready freddy you embarrassment
you're the worst freddy
oh
thank you
i'm curious
oh oh what
what whoa
whoa
bug i found one what the hell
so if you
bring freddy close to a door that's
level 10 it'll open for him
oh weird
oh cool
i like that
i like knowing about that i'm going to
use that i'm going gonna use that a lot
all right
interesting
all right freddie get over here god damn
it freddy
okay thank you for opening that
thank you
interesting
fascinating okay so utility tunnels no
this isn't where i need to be goddammit
this is not oh i thought this was gonna
be
why am i having so much trouble just
navigating these simple areas
i don't know why
for some reason i seem to be incapable
of the proper navigation no that goes
behind it that's not where i need to go
i need to go the atrium
the atrium
yes
finally i made it okay roxy's raceway
wait this is roxy's raceway
roxy's raceway
moxie raceway
do you know where uh you said roxy
raceway you were able to get in here do
you know where uh you would be able to
get into
also uh can you make sure that you stay
full power because i'm going to
be wandering for a bit
you did say that you could get her in
there
it says that's temporarily closed but
you said you were able to get in but how
find out how to stop roxy and roxy
raceway all right
there's got to be a way to get in here
i just got to do
an order
unless these doors here were to roxy
raceway
maybe
hello don't mind me just here for the
race
here to fix the machines don't worry
about a thing i got this
all under control thank you yes i'm in
now
uh-huh
okay
i'm in the raceway now
follow along pal
best friend
buddy
hi
how you doing
yeah
come along pal
we're gonna go on an adventure
oh i thought i could drop down there
um
so
what is with the loading issues so
wow
so what i'm gathering is that there
needs to be something here
that is not where i go
freddy you seeing a way through this
loading's a little odd
oh
of course
that was
what
hold on i have to stop for a second and
just process what happened
for those of you who don't
know what just happened
i had to approach that gate that gate
with freddie
in freddy and then when he got close he
automatically like
either shouted fuceroda style or punched
i didn't see he was a little laggy
and the door opened had i not been in
freddie i would never have known what to
do at that point
and there was no indication of what
i was supposed to do
okay just wanted to get just want to
work that through in my head nothing
else to say about i just want to say
that out loud so i can get it all out in
the open every day there's a new problem
we pour in a section of the track and as
soon as it dries we start to see cracks
i'm worried we are building over a
sinkhole here before construction was
approved there was a site evaluation
right
oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
come along fredster
i'm
roxanne wolf
if you're looking for high-speed motor
mayhem roxy raceway is the place to be
sign up today and be a winner
nobody likes a loser
well you know i guess you don't like
yourself then because you are the
biggest loser i've ever known
sucks to be you
sucks to be you roxy
all right how do i race
and then i bet they're not gonna let me
actually race
as rad and as dope as it would be to
race roxanne
no no no no
you chased me you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] don't tell me that your
orbiting pattern was just there
no you're a dick
a dick in a dick hole
hi pal
okay so what am i doing and where am i
doing it
ah
some over there
that looks important
pathetic okay sore winner roxy did it
again another brain dead staff bought
decapitated because it got in her way on
the race tack track i'm getting really
sick of trudging over the west arcade to
fix these things why isn't there a staff
repair station any closer at least i
have an extra dance pass so i won't get
locked out again you got a dance pass
you got one of them dance passes
oh god i hate this
now this is a trap that's a trappy trap
okay today we broke through the
foundation and found what looks like an
old elevator shaft someone must have
known about this right there's something
down here pulling power i'm taking a
team down in the morning to check it out
i'm sure they're all alive and well
i'm sure they're doing just fine
just
fine hello
i'm here for the power pole dance party
okay so i'm not here yet until i
get the claw upgrade i bet
okay
you got it i'll be back
oh my god
hi
okay back to the matter at hand which is
racing and kicking roxy's ass
uh where's the line for the ass kicking
is there like uh
an ass cue
[Music]
yeah
nothing no
okay i went the wrong way but that's
fine it's what i always do i'm very
exploratory i'm very thorough that's why
i'm a winner i always check the corners
first so i know exactly where i
shouldn't be before going to where i
should be hello
okay where is am i
oh what are you doing in there
what are you doing in there do you have
authorization to be here well i'm coming
after you for your credentials don't
look at mine
give me your credentials immediately
i'll take one of these
oh
okay thank you
okay princess quest two won't boot
properly no idea why shuts down when i
try to play like it's personal doesn't
matter i still found princess quest
are you doing what are you doing what
are you doing don't don't don't no no oh
god you sucking suck ass
don't don't don't i'll shoot you i'll
shoot you i'll shoot you yeah
that's what i thought that's what i
thought that's what i thought
that's what i thought you loser
you don't wanna mess with winner like me
you're gonna get it
stop stop it cease your activities
immediately i'm now in freddy and you
cannot harm me
for some reason that's how that works
oh my battery's almost dead how's my
battery almost dead it was almost fully
charged
dance pass
i got the dance pass
yeah i know
but i got the dance pass
whoa
stop that
my battery's dead
i think there was a charger over here
somewhere police on the entrance they're
worse
oh but i'm never going to be able to get
back to the entrance because i went the
stupid way
i mean the smart thorough way
can i get back this way
please yes yes yes
okay
maybe something about jumping into the
power station without freddie
caused my something to plug out in the
power to drain
thank you
oh my why
how
boy you're going back behind the thing
god
you are the most aggravating thing i've
ever seen seen
okay i'm calm i'm calm i'm cool i'm
relaxed um chill i am so sorry gregory
it appears you are not tall enough to
ride the guards alone
you will need a working driver assist
spot in order to use this card oh man
the robot's missing its head
what
we're running out of test boss for the
raceway at this point we're down to a
single driver assist bod safekeeping
we're storing it to the back of the
raceway near the northwest stairs
very specific back at the raceway near
the northwest stairs if only i knew
which way north was
i now know which way north is
perfect
let me just save you sue
and what's up here
hello
fizzy fazz roxy what does that even mean
they've got up arrows
but i don't know what they mean
fizzy fazz freddy fizzy vaz roxy
it's off something
stamina up i don't know
not really specific but whatever
i'll get to it eventually
can i go this way no can i go rounded
from the behind
this is where the sinkhole is
maybe
maybe it was right by the safe station
yeah it was right by the safe station it
was literally next to the safe station
nope or it wasn't
or it was not
or is this weird back area
all right
great
good
[Applause]
how do i get over there
how do i get over there crouch no
i walk
i walk around i just couldn't walk
through the other things
all right it's got to be back here
somewhere this is kind of where they
were saying back behind the stairs i
don't know if it's upstairs or
downstairs
is that this is what i'm looking for
those are lovely drawings
monty balloon that's absolutely not what
i'm looking for hey i didn't do it
power drain we keep getting those brown
outs so i got fed up and did a little
investigation it looks like something is
drawing a massive amount of power from
the work site we've traced a high
voltage cable that disappears right into
the foundation there's definitely
something under us we're going to bore
back into the foundation and find out
what it is
well that seems like an easy fix just
dig right down there i'm sure that won't
have any repercussions just go for it
why even ask why even get approval dig
dig dig dig okay
is it down here
it's down here
out of order what the door
okay
fire
why fire
wife oh it's hot
what
oh
hi freddy um
hi
good god
dude
i see all right i'ma hop in now
can you do something about the door here
no
no okay
i don't know if i'm supposed to be down
i'm a little confused i thought i was
definitely going to be done
okay
i don't know what the
is there a missing robot i had down here
i don't know man i don't know
what is the hell in the happening what
why is this here
what is going on
i feel like there should be
like something down there i see race
parts but
what in the hell
did i do wrong
how in the hell did i get there
i don't know man i don't know
i'm just your little let's player trying
to do my best
i'm trying to play the game i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm really sorry
okay so not there apparently
let me try going up the stairs
i guess
no can't go up the stairs then was that
the right way to go
what
isn't this the northwest north e these
are northeast ah i need to go further
west
ah i got my east and west mixed up
i see
i was not supposed to be there
that's the answer and i'm sticking to it
retheme the bowling alley needs to
retheme while most of bonnie's art was
removed kids keep asking where's bonnie
do we have an officially approved
response where is bonnie
why would you just scrub bonnie away
from everything
i mean don't get me wrong
i love monkey
oh do i have to go all the way around i
bet i have to go all the way around i
bet they're gonna make me do that
wait nope don't go that way go straight
through
just cut right through be very direct
this way perfect
okay
i just noticed that you must be this
tall sign i didn't know that
i mean i didn't know it was there i just
they started talking about height and i
was like okay i guess i'm
not tall enough but whatever
would have been great if i saw the sign
first
oh well
it is what is
you know they were talking about roxy
winning a lot of races
but that doesn't seem to be the case if
if this has been out of commission like
at least some of the messages right some
of the messages were very specific like
hey there's something going on with the
race
some bad oh
hi
really
really this is what you this is what you
put here
okay
yeah feeling about that
yeah okay all right okay thanks
thank you all
good job you have found a driver
assistant
i do not believe it will work in that
condition though however there is a
staff repair station in the west arcade
you will need a dance pass to access the
west arcade have you checked the party
garages
the raceway was closed very abruptly
prior to the new construction
guests tend to leave things behind
during emergency situations
yeah they do yeah they do you know they
sure do
sniper shot
okay
so now i gotta go to the west arcade to
repair this head because it was broken
and so that means i'm gonna go back this
way but before i do that i'm gonna say
goodbye for now thank you everybody so
much for watching this game has ups and
downs there's moments when i really feel
like that five nights at freddy's
connections
and like it's really really there
specifically in certain spots
however there are certain moments when
i'm just like
okay
okay but i'm willing to let those go
because
part of me just like i there's there's
still that carrot on a stick that's
drawing me down into it so thank you
everybody so much for watching check the
links in the description for these cool
clothing and my podcast called
distractible it's lovely and fun and i
hope you enjoy it and uh yeah more
episodes coming too soon thank you and
as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you